breakdown but my art was gone I lost my
ability to write and 15 years after that
is when Jay contacts me and says that he
wants to do a documentary about me I had
no idea who he was but as we like
reignited my career I've been turning
film festivals for over a year in half
because of his documentary Kevin so it's
like I have an opportunity now I'm just
trying to take full advantage of it
can't I have to be the feet or all in
front of people like this I just love it
so that's the story that I more
questions for so during the the time of
your disappearance in terms of internet
visibility where were you emotionally
what were you doing for a job and what
kept you going during that time I was
working at UPS in Austin idea I worked
the morning shift there from 40 m 2 9am
and I would when I got off I would kind
of got to this running kick outdoor high
school track and just run because kind
of replace the energy of music I didn't
know how to describe that feeling I want
any of your artists but the ability to
create was just not available to me and
I had taken that for granted because it
used to be just like having conversation
and I was around a lot of musicians and
performed and hosted open mic literally
intimate theater so when you're hearing
people always perform and narrowing and
recite and you see them acted kinda I
didn't know this but that's how he
learned it feeds and it inspires you so
I was constantly writing because of that
by the club the club closed in 1995 and
I just stopped writing and it wasn't
until Jay contacted me again that that
switched her
so thankful last question so what does
the good my promise song entail what
does it mean to you and how did you sort
of formulate what goes into it you guys
contacted me and asked me to write the
song and you were wise in doing so and
it kind of I'm so inspired by the movie
because I realized that I can't remember
the figure there was another movie where
it kind of mentioned how many thousands
of people come into Los Angeles a month
because they want to be a star they
having a career in the entertainment
industry and how many people leave every
month there's some crazy number like
10,000 or something like that and all of
those people as talented as they are
they're completely done and there's
nothing that's going to happen and this
individual in this movie gives himself
70 years and I don't even notice how
this is the movie has inspired me so
much because there's nothing to document
all of the amazingly talented people
that didn't change their name from Norma
Jean America we don't even that's not
going to happen for 99.999 so you know
what do you do with result it's feast or
famine and i'm not actually experiencing
that now and have missed any meals but
there's just kind of an adventure here
that's what it's on going to always be
you know there's not an apparatus set up
for us to unless you kindly kind of
finally latch onto something that fits
you your heart and conversate I don't
know the rest of us have to be able to
express ourselves and if we're going to
continue to do it it comes down to faith
so I'm literally living on that now so
that's why they had to turn starving
artist I've ever heard of safe driving
artists they never speak I would love
that to be the norm one day
oh I have CDs thank you I have CDs and
DVDs with me and I won't put any
pressure thanks for allowing me to do
this but those of you that have the I
have the documentary on the city that I
would love to sell to those of you who
can afford it and no pressure but come
right up to me and interrupt me if I'm
talking to someone else don't be afraid
because I could really use it right now
so thank you so much so kind of guilty
now
comes a time in every artist life we
know about to the side what are the
worldly gonna to keep our dreams the
seven years i think i'll roll the dice
you're calling the dr my dreams do not
come true I've got a whole money
keep my goodbye
a little filet mignon sure would be nice
to go with my ramen noodle appetizer
everyone's gotta pay their dues you want
to live life
so for seven years I'll pay the price
and give Hollywood a try have my dreams
tonight don't you on the whole my head
it's my goodbye promise to the sky
I'm good bye
would always be all right Renee minyan
sure would have been nice you got my
ramen the new Apple times but in all I
could to pay my dues I sure will many
before us help pay the ultimate price
getting Hollywood a truck
so if I dreams come true I'm still gonna
hold
I promised my goodbyes promise is that
all
I'm gonna always be all right
it's not my qualities do or die there
are more important things waiting for
cell phones doing
and I refused
bye goodbye goodbye promises that I be
starting
me list celebrity
by the summer seven years organic scusi
resulting in virtual and
I will go ahead let go of this lala land
i fantasy
and finally kiss
passionate
Hollywood goodbye